if you miss a line in the game you reset
you miss it on the track
you could die
who do you think the best driver is
probably Rory I would dust him in a lap
yeah all you do is clean video games
with some crazy dreams of racing cars
Doug you're the one that told us to
always do something we love you know
what racing cars cost
look around it's not our world son
what is this it's a contest
the best Gran Turismo players in the
world
get a chance to compete in professional
racing dude this is real
[Applause]
I'm sorry you really think you're gonna
take a kid who plays video games in
their bedroom you're gonna strap them to
a 200 mile an hour rocket it'll tear
them to pieces
the guys who race are Elite athletes
the kids are scrawny little gamer kids
well that's why you coming
must be a new experience for you moving
your legs
you puked on my lawn there's no turning
back man when you're in a race the
cockpit is going to be 140 degrees
Fahrenheit
g-forces will be twice when an astronaut
experiences upon liftoff I can't see
anything
hey you get extra points for that in the
game Jesus Christ
I'll never give up this whole thing is
insane but out of the Couchsurfing nerds
that you sent me he is the best one he
made it yeah yeah welcome to Team Nissan
of the game it's called racing
if you miss a line in the game you reset
you miss it on the track
you could die
I know this track
my braced it a thousand times
that's what I'm talking about